Oh my god, you grew up
Hey your dad told me that you're thinking about coming up here for college. That's exciting. Yeah, maybe
You new to town?
I'm visiting my aunt
I'm Katie
Cyd
Hey I get off in about ten minutes if you want to, I don't know go for a walk or something?
Okay
Your aunt cool? Yeah, she is a writer
You write a lot about religion you really believe in like a heaven and hell and all that
I believe in grace, I believe in a complete meaning somewhere
You really think we're gonna see my mom again?
Do you ever have sex?
Sorry is that..?
Okay, yeah sure I do. Really? Yeah. When, with who?
Just trying to think
Yeah, Myranda. What I'm trying to think! It's been forever hasn't it?
Can't tell you a secret? I kinda wanna have sex with Katie
What is that weird?
Not at all
So you were both married to men?
I was a widow, Betty was married, got divorced.
So you liked it and you didn't
Are you asking if we liked it?
So it is not a handicap to have one thing but not another
We are different shapes and ways and our happiness is unique
So what are you into?
Everything